hi my name's Samuel Leeds and in this
video I want to give you some
differences between poor people and rich
people the way they think differently
the way they act differently so this is
seven things that differentiate the rich
and the poor
[Music]
number one poor people find problems or
avoid problems whereas rich people solve
problems number two
poor people spend their money or save
their money whereas rich people invest
their money number three
poor people complain if there's a
problem or they don't like something
they moon whereas rich people create
number four poor people
stop learning when they finish school
rich people are always learning
number five poor people get stopped
easily rich people do whatever it takes
and are unstoppable
number six poor people play it safe
whereas rich people place a twin and
I've appeared to take risks and number
seven poor people think or whereas rich
people think both what I mean by this
well if you're watching this and you're
thinking yeah I could be rich but I'd
rather be happy that's an all question
I'm rich person will say I'll have both
I hope you found that video useful and
if you know people who are guilty of
thinking like a poor person when really
they deserve to be wealthy and think
rich then please do share the heck out
of this video with all your family and
friends and don't forget to subscribe so
you never miss a future video thanks so
much
[Music]
you
[Music]